if you watched my first xbox series x
preview i covered backwards
compatibility and performance
low times and quick resume and have a
few more details on that
but i have a lot more to discuss now
including series x specific games and
enhancements
external storage options and how well
they work and more on the overall next
gen experience
keep in mind that this is not a review
rather a more detailed look at our
series x preview units
so let's kick things off with talking
about some real next-gen games
i've had access to early builds of a few
series x specific games such as yakuza
like a dragon and dirt 5
and the series x optimized versions of
gears tactics and gears 5.
as a big time yakuza fan leica dragon is
one of my most anticipated games of the
year
and this demo filled me with so much joy
and excitement but instead of waxing
poetic about how lovely and wild it is
let's look at its next-gen performance
you get three enhancement options here
high resolution gives you full native 4k
resolution but runs around 30 fps
normal gives you 1440p resolution with a
consistent 60fps
high framerate does 1080p also add 60fps
but negates potential frame drops if
they come up
i mostly play on normal and didn't think
twice about switching because for me
it's the best balance it looks great and
maintains high fps
so there's really no need to drop the
visual quality further for the high
frame rate mode
leica dragon's yokohama is a wonderfully
detailed setting and the best use of the
yakuza series dragon engine
which was used in kiwami 2 yakuza 6 and
judgment
it looks and runs great
dirt 5 also presents 3 enhancement
options image quality aims for full 4k
while using dynamic resolution to try to
maintain
60fps but it seemed to me that there
were some frame drops when particle
effects kicked up while a bunch of cars
were on screen
frame rate mode also uses dynamic
resolution but lacks some visual flair
reducing effects like shadow quality to
maintain a more consistent 60fps
if you have a 120hz display and set the
system output to 120hz
dirt 5 will offer the 120hz option
as a pc gamer who's been on high refresh
rate monitors for quite some time
it's a real treat to see a console game
hit 120 fps
sure the graphical quality takes a hit
but in return the game moves buttery
smooth
the visual compromises are quite
apparent to me but i wouldn't say it
makes the game look bad
overall though i do feel image quality
is the best option here
both yakuza like a dragon and dirt 5 are
cross gen games
so while they might not blow you away
with the next gen wow factor
there are measurable graphical
improvements over what we'd expect from
the xbox one x
with gears tactics it keeps things
simple on the xbox series x the game
runs at 4k
60fps no options or compromises
necessary
this is in contrast to the xbox one x
where you have the option for 4k
30fps with quality mode and 1440p 60fps
with performance mode
the bump in frame rate is nice but this
being a turn based strategy game doesn't
have that much of an effect on the
experience
certainly not as much as it would on a
racing game such as dirt 5
or a shooter like gears 5. so with gears
5 you get a new option with the xbox
series x
120 fps in multiplayer of course this
only matters if your display can do 120
hertz
4k or otherwise and from what i can tell
the jump in frame rate is a great touch
to make the action noticeably smoother
the bump won't affect the single player
campaign though it will run a dynamic 4k
at 60fps like the one x but with a few
perks like improved anisotropic
filtering and more consistent
performance and image quality due to the
stronger hardware
performance in backwards compatible
games really depends on how they're
built
what their technical limitations are and
whether or not they've been updated with
series x optimizations
i mentioned this in my first preview
that final fantasy xv for example
runs at a much more consistent fps on
series x when set to its performance
mode whereas on the one x
you'll experience some noticeable frame
drops however using the higher quality
mode still caps the game at 30 fps on
both systems
since the game is built with that frame
cap when running high fidelity modes
on that note other games that cap the
frame rate at 60fps will be able to
actually hit that high mark
and or maintain it more consistently
than the xbox one
as made evident in games such as monster
hunter world sekiro shadows died twice
no man's sky and plenty more but a game
like the outer worlds which caps at
30fps and doesn't have graphics
options will still run at 30fps on
either system
more recently i cracked into doom
eternal the game maintains consistent
performance with 60fps but runs a
dynamic resolution that maxes out at
1800p on the xbox one x
and turns it down when things get hectic
on the xbox series x
it's able to keep resolution at or
closer to 1800p
since the hardware is powerful enough to
do this and still hit 60fps
so in short if a game uses dynamic
resolution or allows higher fps
you'll get improvements by virtue of the
more powerful series x hardware
even if there aren't series x
optimizations if a game is bound by
certain technical limitations such as a
30 fps cap or a fixed resolution
the game will have to adhere to that
accordingly it just depends on how the
game is built
of course it's possible that some games
could also get updates for sears x
optimizations in the future
so keep in mind that these conditions
can change one such case is destiny 2
which caps at 30 fps for now
but will improve to 60fps when its next
gen update rolls around
load times are one of the biggest
improvements you get with the xbox
series x
the console really leverages that solid
state drive as you'll see
in our results so this is where you're
gonna get that practical benefit that
permeates the entire experience
we previously used four games to test
load time improvements and to quickly
summarize
we got the following results on one x
and series x when loading a save
from the title screen red dead
redemption 2 went from 2 minutes and 8
seconds
down to 38 seconds control went from 58
seconds
to 10 seconds final fantasy 15 went from
1 minute and 11 seconds to 13 seconds
and the outer worlds went from 43
seconds to 11 seconds
we did a similar comparison with gears 5
and gears tactics
both of which are cross-gen games with
series x optimizations
gears 5 went from 28 seconds on the 1x
to just
5 seconds on the series x to load into
act 1 mission 3
and gear's tactics improved greatly as
well going from 52 seconds
to 18 seconds to load into a mission
when it comes to ongoing multiplayer
games you're constantly going back to
you'll definitely be saving some time
take destiny 2 and its current state for
example on 1x
getting from sign in to character select
took a minute and 34 seconds
and loading from orbit to the trostlin
edz took 1 minute and 12 seconds
on the series x the game took about 18
seconds and 21 seconds
for those respective scenarios while
yakuza like a dragon and dirt 5 will be
available on xbox one we didn't have
access to those versions for this
preview
but to give you an idea of what to
expect on series x
loading a save in yakuza took just 6
seconds
and hopping into career mode race in
dirt 5 took about 12 seconds
the time you save adds up in both games
since you're frequently loading into
different scenarios and scenes in yakuza
and entering races in dirt 5. after
having spent a bunch of time on the xbox
series x the differences are night and
day which makes it hard to go back to
the hard drives of old
on xbox one and ps4 the xbox series x
comes with a one terabyte
internal ssd which actually comes out to
802 gigabytes of free storage you get to
use
and with the size of games today that
might fill up fast so you have a few
options in terms of how you can bulk up
your storage now there are some
important details that you'll need to
consider
so first let's start with the one
terabyte seagate ssd that slots right
into the console
this is technically the best solution
since it's identical to the internal ssd
there's virtually no difference in load
times in our testing using the games i
previously mentioned
it's built specifically to interface
with the xbox hardware
and comes with all the same benefits
like running series x and s
specific games without a hitch however
it carries a hefty price tag at
220 bucks the other solution is to get
an external usb
3.0 drive but things can get a little
tricky here
you'll be able to play backwards
compatible xbox one and previous gen
games
straight off the drive but not series x
optimized games
you can still use it to store series x
games but to play them
you'll need to transfer them to the
internal drive or expansion card if you
have one
this can also apply to certain xbox one
games that have received series x
optimizations as was the case in gears 5
and gears tactics
i tested this out using a samsung t5
external ssd
and a usb 3.1 cable and in terms of
moving data around
and loading the results were very very
impressive
the outer worlds is a 45 gigabyte game
and took 2 minutes and 54 seconds
to move to the external ssd and when
loading into the same save as a previous
test
it only took 13 seconds which is
extremely close to the internal ssd
speeds
final fantasy 15 is an 84 gigabyte file
and took longer to transfer
at 5 minutes and 50 seconds but the load
time results were great
just taking 15 seconds with the external
ssd
of course both are xbox one games
without series x optimizations so the
results between internal
and external storage come from the fact
that the games are working off of ssd
speeds
but since external usb ssds can only
play xbox one games anyway
and can still do quick resume this is a
great solution for them
especially when something like the
samsung t5 is more cost effective at
around 110 bucks for 500 gigabytes
and 140 bucks for one terabyte now
you're probably wondering how the xbox
series x has revamped the ui
but let's just say that nothing has
really changed at all at least
not for now
[Music]
now what you see here is not the final
interface again this is all in a preview
state and is subject to change somewhat
by launch
the cold boot up is quite fast as you
see here and navigating the interface is
much snappier than it has been in xbox's
past
and a cold boot up of games themselves
is of course faster as well a big note
on the quick resume feature though
all games that have been suspended
through quick resume will retain their
suspended state
if you turn off the console and even if
you unplug the console too
i did encounter a few rare bugs where
games like yakuza dirt 5 and gears 5
froze when trying to jump back in thus
requiring a full reboot of the game
we should expect these hiccups to be
worked out in the system's final build
however
i do think it's really nice to have 5 to
6 games simultaneously suspended and
be able to jump between them in a matter
of 8 ish seconds
without loading anything else even if
you don't juggle that many games
this feature still benefits the handful
of games you keep coming back to
and it's not like you have a choice to
use it quick resume is just built into
the way the series x works
i do wish there was some sort of
notification that let you know when
you're pushing the limits and have to
close a game's suspended state though
i think we've exhausted all the
conversations around the xbox series x's
brick like design
and we've seen it from all different
angles and we've seen it stacked against
other consoles
but a big topic that has come up is heat
yes the xbox series x gets hot
the top half of the console gets quite
warm to the touch and the air that's
blown out from the top exhaust is hot as
well
as is the case with most high-end
computers i haven't had any issues with
overheating but you should be mindful of
giving the series x's top exhaust enough
room if you're fitting it in a tight
space
on the bright side though the system
runs whisper quiet even under heavy load
keep in mind that this is a non-final
version of the system
so thermal management could
theoretically change with all that said
i'm sure someone out there has measured
the exact operating temperatures of the
system but i'm gonna hold off until we
get the final retail build
so there it is our last extensive
preview of the xbox series x
before it launches on november 10th so
far we've seen measurable performance
and graphical improvements with series x
optimized games
even if they may not blow you away with
backwards compatibility the boosts we
see now are genuinely exciting and will
continue to be
as more games get proper enhancements of
course fast load times keep on
impressing and although there were some
hiccups that occurred i'm still a fan of
quick resumes functionality
i've tried to highlight the aspects of
next-gen that i think matter most
but i can't cover every little detail
all in one go
so if you have any remaining questions
feel free to hit me up in the comments
below or on twitter at michaelp heim and
i will do my best to try and answer them
in detail on our weekly show
jen next thank you all for watching and
i'll see you all
next time
you